if you ask the question why are some
drugs legal and others illegal why are
cigarettes and alcohol legal and
pharmaceuticals in the middle and these
other drugs marijuana was illegal you
know some people sort of inherently
assume well this must be because there
was a thoughtful consideration of the
relative risks of drugs and you know but
then you think well I can't because we
know alcohol is more associated with
violence in almost any illegal drugs and
cigarettes are more addictive than any
of the illegal drugs I mean heroin
addicts routinely say it's harder to
quit cigarettes than it is to quit
heroin so so it's not as if there was
ever any kind of National Academy of
Science that a hundred years ago decided
that these drugs these ones had to be
illegal and those ones legal and it's
not as if this is in the Bible or in the
code of hammurabi I mean nobody was
making legal distinctions among many of
these drugs back and until the 20th
century essentially so if you ask how
and why this distinction got made what
you realize when you look at the history
is it has almost nothing to do with the
relative risks of these drugs and almost
everything to do with who used and who
was perceived to use these drugs right
so there's you know back in the 1870s
when the majority of opiate consumers
were middle-aged white women you know
throughout the country using them for
their aches and pains and further you
know when they you know time of the
month and menopause and there was no
aspirin there was no penicillin you know
lots of diarrhea cuz a bad sanitation
and nothing stops you up like opiates I
mean millions many more how much higher
percentage of the population back then
used opiates and now but nobody thought
about criminalizing it because nobody
wanted to put you know auntie or grandma
behind bars right but then when the
Chinese start coming to the country in
large numbers in the 1870s and 80s and
you know working on the railroads and
working in the mines and working in
factories and you know and then anything
going back home at the end of the night
to smoke up a little opium the way they
did in the old country the same way
white people were having a couple of
whiskey's in the evening and that's when
you got the first opium prohibition laws
in Nevada in California in the 1870s and
80s
directed at the Chinese minorities it
was all about the fear would what would
those Chinamen with her opium do to our
precious women you know you know
addicting them and seducing them and
turning them into sex slaves and all
this sort of stuff
the first anti cocaine laws were in the
South in the early part of the 20th
century directed at black men working on
the docks in the fear you know what
would happen to those black men when
they took that white powder up their
black noses and forgot their proper
place in society you know going out
first time anybody ever says that you
know cops needed a 38 will not bring
down a Negro craze on cocaine you needed
a 45 I mean the New York Times you know
the paper of record reporting this stuff
as as fact back in those days that's
when you got the first cocaine
prohibition laws the first marijuana
prohibition laws were in the Midwest and
the Southwest directed at Mexican
migrants Mexican Americans taking the
good jobs from the good white people
going back home to their communities
smoking a little less funny smoking you
know marijuana reefer cigarette and once
again the fear what would this minority
do to our precious women and children so
it mean it's always been about that I
mean even alcohol prohibition was to
some extent a broader conflict between
the white white Americans and then
that's so white white Americans right
the white white Americans coming from
northern and western Europe in the 18th
through a 19th century with all of their
stuff and then the the not so white
white Americans coming from southern
Europe and Eastern Europe in the late
19th and early 20th century bringing
with them their beer and their vino and
their you know there's little it's right
I mean it was all about that type of
conflict and it wasn't as if the white
white Americans weren't also consuming
it's just many of them knew that when
you criminalize a vice that is engaged
in by a huge minority of the population
and you leave it inevitably to the
discretion of law enforcement as to how
to enforce those laws those laws are not
typically going to be enforced against
the whiter and wealthier and more
affluent or middle-class members of
society inevitably those laws will be
disproportionately enforced against the
poor
and younger and darker skin members of
society so to some very good extent
that's really what the war on drugs has
been about when people talk about it as
the new Jim Crow in this wonderful book
by Michelle Alexander with that title
it's about understanding that you know
the war on drugs is not just about race
and it's not just about targeting black
and brown young people because God knows
I mean millions of white people have
been swept up in the war on drugs as
well but it is disproportionately and
overwhelmingly about that from its
origins to its enforcement to who gets
victimized today